alright guys so we all played about four
hours and followed somebody six beta and
I feel like we all have pretty different
opinions on it it seems like that kind
of game yes it does
I've been thinking a lot about the way
possessed of designs games and I think
that Bethesda strengths comes in
exploration over storytelling based on
like kind of healthy they've designed
all their past games that's that's the
thing that I'm gravitating towards to
this game like that is the strength I
think it has best map that the Fez has
ever made I think they've really nailed
how to make interesting locations and I
think that just exploring it is really
fun
there was a point though where as you're
done exploring everything you kind of go
oh what do I do now and and that's sort
of where I'm at with the game where I'm
still having a really good time and I'm
still really excited to play it but I'm
just sitting there and I'm going well
once I see everything like what do I do
how much of the Mel do you think we
covered last night like in about four
hours
we covered it's a it's a big map and we
kind of stuck to like the like south
southwest side maybe like a sixteenth of
it or something it was it's a big map so
I think you'll you'll definitely get a
lot out of just exploring it for sure
so if Bethesda strength is storytelling
and those are the elements of the game
that you liked sure like environmental
storytelling specifically I kind of feel
like so coming from somebody who played
fallout for almost exclusively as a
shooter without bets
I feel like Bethesda needs to step up
their mechanics to actually get to that
point because I can't point to anything
in particular that was better than
fallout 4 mechanically in this game and
sometimes things were worse like the
shooting was not very much improved it
was very janky and like Riven is a beta
there were some huge framerate drops
like inventory management was as complex
and confusing as ever and like kind of
bulky like it was
I mean this is 2018 we're still loading
the buildings with like really long load
times like Bethesda in my opinion if
they're gonna make this into an
exploration shooter has leaned on
probably the weakest elements of their
game to try and carry that idea and so
you know we only played a couple hours
but I think they've mechanically this
game has a long way to go I think going
off of what you were saying is like
played primarily as a shooter because
the thing with Fallout does the games
for me at least is that you know the
exploration the the storytelling and you
know interacting with NPCs obviously
they're not a part of this game and that
was said like from the from the get-go
so I'm like okay so then what else is
gonna pick it up from there is it the
social aspect and I play primarily as a
solo player to see if that's like a
viable approach and I think that you
know the way this world is built the way
the quests are build almost feel like I
won't say like too much like destiny but
it that there's something there where
you are primarily playing this as a
shooter because of the way vats is set
up like you you don't necessarily pick
out limbs and stop time so you're gonna
combat is basically going to be either
melee or straight-up like a shooter and
like you said I agree that you know the
way the shooting works like fallout it's
based on fallout 4 and 4 had the best
shooting of any Fallout game but it's
still not enough to stand on its own and
here I feel like it's standing on its
own so I agree with that aspect and that
it feels like it's highlighting one of
the weaker parts of Fallout games but at
the same time is it highlights one of
the best parts of Fallout games like the
exploration West Virginia is a beautiful
place albeit run down and like busted
from nuclear fallout obviously but
something about you know going from a
nice autumn landscape to like like an
amusement park where it's it's run-down
but it's it's snowing and it feels
dreary and it's raining
so you have great exploration and you
have janky shooting so I'm constantly
teetering between like am i enjoying
this I think I am but the same time I'm
not it like I go through peaks and
valleys of how I felt through my four
hours and fall at 76 and so to talk
about whether or not it's viable to play
on your own is that you know you don't
have NBC's you don't run into towns and
talk to like whoever the mayor is and
get quest that way but there's a lot of
like notes that are left there's it's
all based on audio logs I feel like
sometimes it's interesting sometimes
it's not so it's very hit-or-miss
there's a there's a real risk with the
audio log technique I mean that's kind
of what the Division two did where so
the division did where everything
already happened before you got there
which is way less interesting than just
meeting people who already exists there
yeah and kind of impacting the world and
they're not there their justification
for that was they're worried you're
gonna shoot we were gonna get confused
between NBC and players like NPCs and
players dress and act very differently I
don't know like Ben you you you like the
coop a lot like I remember last night
you were really into it see the lowest
point of the whole experience and that
made it for me was we were actually
trying to do the main questline
because for me the main thing like we're
saying all along is strongest parts of
fallout are the exploration and
discovery and I was having a good time
just going around doing that for the
beginning part of it and the fact that I
could do it with you guys at the same
time was really cool there was photo
mode we got to like take pictures to be
like ah here's the Mothman museum we've
we found some Mothman eggs just be able
to go around with your pals was a good
time but talking to robots and going
down to a river to get an audio log
about how a person like drank water and
died was not a big thing for me there
was a great debate last night as to
whether we should eat the Mothman eggs
or not yeah I did it yeah it was not
worth it yeah but science you know I was
kind of struck by there were public
events in this game oh yeah like how I
even like first like how did you feel
about as a solo player were you drawn
into other players that brings up
another thing
you know there's about 70 ish players
that get dropped into one instance but
throughout most of my time I had like a
when I played three three-and-a-half
hours four hours I only like I dropped
into a public event and there were like
two or three dudes there and we all
joined in on we killed like 15 robots or
whatever that were invading this
particular space like I was a public
event and I said I said yeah well like
sup man and then they're like nothin
thanks for joining the public van all
right see you later and that was the
last time I saw someone on the map and
so I don't really think this as it is as
it stands right now it's not really
built to like oh I'm gonna run into a
player and we're going to team up and or
we're going to like you're not gonna
constantly run some public events where
there's gonna be a lot of players there
at least that's how I feel so I feel
like the multiplayer aspect really banks
on you finding a group of friends to
actually go out and explore because it's
not dense at all
yeah and it's weird how there's a lack
of players in that server yeah like I'd
one-hand I kind of like it cuz it does
make it feel special when you do run in
another person which is kind of what
they were okay they said that's where
they were sort of going for but on the
other hand I felt like we had to
actively seek out people we did want to
run into them to the point where it
being multiplayer outside of co-op felt
almost inconsequential to the overall
experience where it's like well I'm just
kind of occasionally running into these
people and like we try to murder
somebody because we're like eyelets yeah
let's do this
and it's like impossible
the the like anti like ganking measures
for like going in and actually just
trying to pvp against someone it's
almost impossible to kill someone unless
they fire back yeah and we figured that
out the worst way which is like three is
four is like okay well you won't have a
bad experience but then at that point
you're like is there is no experience
like yeah two interacting with these
players in like a big way at least so
far like there seem to be some mixed
messages from the game on that front
like the player density was too low for
this to happen but we ran into two
different settlements where it was
almost like a capture the flag moment it
told us to take the settlement and then
gave us a message that other players
could come and fight us for it which is
a cool idea but it's like I don't know
there's like no one near us all maps was
I guess we could just stand here for a
couple hours and wait for people they're
like yeah yeah so the last thing I'll
say from my experience is that yeah I do
want to try this to co-op with Corsa for
four hours I went alone but I do want to
experience what that's like to interact
with the group and kind of explore this
with other people but you know I'm still
like I want to put more time into it
obviously like I'm intrigued by the
environment itself like I didn't get to
go to the south areas of West Virginia
all I went to the north and the East
End's and I'm like looking at that map
itself it's I wonder what's around the
corner there so I'm at least interested
in putting a lot more time into it just
to see you know if there there are some
cool notes that I can pick up at a
certain town like I went to Grafton and
I thought that was like the whole thing
with the parade and the monsters and the
robots running their own city like I
thought that was really interesting so I
expect more of that as I go into more
towns and explore the rest of this huge
map yeah I think I'll have like that
that'll at the very least I'm gonna have
a good time with that where I'm gonna
get the game I'm gonna explore the whole
map have a fun time outside of that I
don't know you know how long it's gonna
last like as a continuing like this game
will live forever I'm just like oh maybe
good 30 40 hours yeah right it'll be
good good 40 hours hopefully yeah I
don't think Bethesda can get away with
janky mechanics anymore they've gotten
away with it for a long time
is a good storytelling and storytelling
is we don't know how good it's gonna be
this time around they're leaning heavily
on mechanics they need to step it up
honestly and it could be good but it
needs to get better yeah I would agree
with that this game I feel like needs to
evolve over time like to to last
[Music]